alright so apple's 2025k imac is here
and i fully believe that it's the very
last intel imac
update ever and it's going out with a
bang
it's an absolute powerhouse of a machine
but it also now has more upgrade options
than ever before making it tough to
figure out which model
and which upgrades to buy for your
specific use case
and since you guys appreciate the
buyer's guides that i've made in the
past
i'm gonna do it again and in this video
i'm
going to talk about the eight mistakes
you should avoid when purchasing
your 2020 imac and then i'm gonna break
down which upgrade you should buy
for different use cases like for casual
users
photo editors programmers logic pro
users
gamers video editors and more but before
we begin
i want to mention that we've already
ordered two of these 2025k imacs
so if you want to see us do a bunch of
testing subscribe
right now and be sure to check out our
new apple product pattern face mask
down below the first mistake you should
avoid is buying the nano texture glass
option
for 500 yes it's probably the best way
to get a matte display
without using a film that ruins the
colors and contrast
but for five hundred dollars unless you
sit right next to a huge window
it's definitely not worth it the nano
texture glass
actually does reduce display sharpness
not as much as other matte displays
but it still does and the imac is
already so bright
that most reflections aren't really an
issue so keep that 500
for something else onto mistake number
two absolutely do not
buy the 21.5 inch imac for three reasons
first off it hasn't been upgraded at all
except for coming with an ssd
at the base price second you can't
upgrade the ram yourself like you can do
in the 5k model
and third we're expecting this smaller
imac to get replaced
with a new 24-inch apple silicon mac
either at the end of this year
or in the first quarter of 2021 for
mistake number three
do not pay for apple's memory upgrades
simply leave it at the 8 gig option even
if you get a fully specced out imac
and that's because apple greatly
overcharges for ram
and you can actually buy ram yourself
from amazon
using our links down below in the
description so you can save up to two
thousand one hundred dollars on 128 gigs
of ram
and it doesn't void your warranty and if
you're not sure about how to do it
it's incredibly easy and we already
created a three minute long
ram upgrade tutorial video that i'll
link to after this video is over
so definitely check that out for mistake
number four you need to realize that on
apple's 5k imac listing page they have
three different option pages
and not all of the available upgrades
are visible on each page
for example if you click on the eighteen
hundred dollar model
you won't have the option to upgrade the
cpu or the graphics
but on the twenty three hundred dollar
model you can even configure
the brand new 10 core cpu and you have
access to three graphics options
that are only available from that page
so be sure to check all of them out
and that actually brings us into mistake
number five
if you really want the new 10 core cpu
and you don't really care about graphics
you need to realize that you can
actually select the middle
2 000 model and pay 500
for that cpu upgrade for a total price
of 2500.
if you would have chosen the highest end
model and upgraded to that same 10 core
cpu
your total would be at 2700 so you need
to realize that you can save money this
way
because you're not forced into getting
better graphics if you don't need it now
mistake number six
is actually the complete opposite this
mistake
is overspending on upgrades you don't
really need
we believe that there is only a small
number of people
who the 10 core cpu is actually worth it
for and i'll talk about it in just a
minute
in the buyer's guide portion so in
reality most people should be fine with
either the 6 core or the 8 core cpu
and the same thing goes for the graphics
there are some people who really won't
benefit at all
from upgrading graphics for mistake
number seven don't accidentally miss out
on the 10 gigabit ethernet upgrade
option
for only a hundred dollars this one
could be very important
because if you don't get it right away
you won't be able to upgrade it yourself
in the future and because this new 5k
imac does not have wi-fi 6
anybody who has or might potentially get
fiber internet in the future
should definitely pay for this 10
gigabit ethernet upgrade
and the same thing goes for anyone who
wants to use a nas
server in the future since you need 10
gig ethernet
for the fastest transfer speeds and even
if you don't fit into one of those
categories
it might make sense to still pay a
hundred dollars for this upgrade
because it'll help the resale value of
your imac in the future
when you decide to sell it since there
may be people who really want the 10 gig
ethernet port
and finally if you want to avoid mistake
number eight
then be wise about how much storage you
buy because
it's not user upgradable with the base
model you're stuck with only 256 gigs of
storage
so if you want more you'll have to
choose the 2 000
model which gives you 512 gigs of
storage and some extra options
i personally think that the one terabyte
ssd option makes a ton of sense for a
lot of people but on the other hand
if you're getting the higher end model
don't go out and upgrade to eight
terabytes of storage
because that's simply insane and way
more than most people need
and you're literally paying more for
that upgrade than the
entire imac itself so now that we've
dealt with all of those purchasing
mistakes
let's get right into the buyer's guide
portion of this video
if you're more of a casual user who
wants a 27-inch imac for things like web
browsing
or using web-based apps like microsoft
office and things like that
then the base 1800 model could actually
be a great choice for you
but keep in mind that it's limited to a
256 gig ssd
so you may want to go for the 2 000
model for more storage
and the small boost and processor
performance now if you're wanting to do
some photo editing
but it's more of a hobby instead of
professional work the two thousand
dollar model should honestly be a great
choice for you
and we recommend getting a one terabyte
ssd and then buying a 32 gigabyte ram
kit from amazon
using the link below and adding it to
the existing ram that comes with the
imac
for a total of 40 gigs of ram which is
more than enough
for your use case now if you're a
high-end photo editor
that takes your work very seriously then
you should definitely get the 2300
model with the 8 core cpu absolutely do
not
upgrade the graphics from the standard
5500 xt
because it really doesn't help photo
editing and it's definitely not worth
the extra cash to upgrade
unless you also do graphics intensive
work or
gaming and honestly we don't think the
10 core cpu is worth it for 99
of photo editors because it's pretty
expensive at 400 dollars
and we don't think it'll make a big
enough performance difference
to justify the price now ram on the
other hand
is very important for photo editing so
we'd recommend getting at least
64 gigs from amazon moving on to
programming
a beginner or casual programmer should
probably be fine with the 2 000
5k imac just be sure to get at least a
32 gigabyte kit of ram
now for a high-end professional
programmer the 10 core cpu might
actually make sense
if you're dealing with very large
projects that take a long time to
compile
and we definitely recommend at least 64
gigs of ram
and absolutely don't upgrade the
graphics for a logic pro 10 user
i honestly think the a core cpu will be
good enough for
99 of users so only the people doing
massive audio projects
should go for the 10 core and for that
it might actually make sense to go all
the way up to 128 gigs of ram
and also keep in mind that graphics
won't do anything
for music production at all now if
you're a gamer especially if you want to
use
boot camp the very first upgrade you
need to make
is go for the 5700 xt graphics card
upgrade
before anything else because this is
currently our favorite amd card
available
and the one we use for our egpu setups
and as far as how much ram you should
buy
a 32 gig kit should be more than good
enough for gaming
and since recent games like call of duty
warzone take a massive amount of storage
i'd recommend bootcamp users to get at
least one terabyte of storage
or maybe even two terabytes so you can
split it up and give one terabyte for
the mac
and one terabyte for windows in boot
camp now if you're wanting to do virtual
machine work
we recommend as much ram as possible so
you can split it up into different vms
and then the 10 core cpu might actually
make sense as well
and definitely be sure to get as much
storage as you think you'll need now
moving on to video editing
if you're working with 1080p clips or
fairly simple 4k
editing without using a lot of extra
effects or luts
then the 2 000 imac will actually get
the job done decently well
with a six core cpu and radeon pro
5300 graphics card you should probably
get a 32 gigabyte ram kit below
and add it to the existing eight gigs
for a total of 40
which is more than good enough and be
sure to get at least a one terabyte ssd
if you're not planning to use external
storage and since
every 2025k imac comes with the t2 chip
you should be able to edit hevc footage
pretty well but if you're planning on
taking video editing more seriously in
the future
you might want to future proof your imac
by going for the 2300
model now for high-end video editing the
most
important thing is the graphics so we
recommend going straight for the 5700 xt
which will be a great match for the 8
core cpu on the 2300
model we honestly believe that the 10
core cpu
isn't worth it for video editing since
it only gives you around a 17
raw performance boost in terms of
geekbench 5 multi-core scores
and that's without factoring in cooling
limitations
we think the only people who should
upgrade to the 10 core cpu
are those who constantly work with raw
footage
like 4k or 8k raw and as for the ram
64 gig should be more than good enough
for video editing
and should probably get at least a one
terabyte ssd
and don't forget about that 10 gigabit
ethernet upgrade
if you think you might be connecting to
a raid storage server in the future
so there you guys have it that's my
buyer's guide for the 2025k
imac so be sure to use those ram links
down below
to save a ton of money on ram and you
can find the 3 minute ram upgrade guide
right up there and click the circle
above to subscribe
and if this video helped you out
consider buying some of our merch like
our mask
down below as a way of saying thank you
thanks for watching and we'll see you
in the next one